et oui récré a2 c'est votre émission
tous les jours pendant les vacances je
ne vais pas être seul pour vous la
présentez rassurez vous je suis en
compagnie d'un goût du goût dit qu'est
ce que ce cas vous dis goody c'est un
héros gentile un western c'est ça ça bah
oui c'est mon goût du goût dit de vous
dit vous dis là de grandes jambes
oui encore qu évidemment une bonne tête
quand même vous pour bien bronzer les
belles dents blanches un regard
pétillant et plein de tendresse
d'intelligence parfois non elle ça joue
la musique par et il avait établi au
pistolet je tire beaucoup plus vite que
tout le monde je suis le plus fort
chômage est en amour c'est gérard hier
ça vous tire de situations les plus
périlleuses pour sûr dorothée tué la
fille du shérif je vais t'emmener dans
ma dit jean st nous allons nous enfuir
loin des indiens way le bétail a passé
la frontière voilà ça te sens pas trop
en arrière et bien écoute match à
dorothée moi aussi je suis très content
d'être à récré a2 et je ne suis pas venu
comme ça j'ai apporté des petites
chansons pour toi le rhdp sont seulement
comme je ne savais pas quel genre de
chanson tu aimais alors j'en ai composé
trois petits trois petites différentes
une ballade rock and roll 1 une petite
berceuse
gprenc écoute alors
et tant mieux
qui d'un livre d'histoire à jour s'est
envolé corps elle connaît des secrets
lutteurs sont ses amis
lt chanter les jouer
dans
re veut être ton ami
raconte
et histoire de soutenir
peux tu être mon ami
pour m'apprendre à chanter comme un
grand cas n'a alors ma vie aussi
dorothée que tu aimais danse et que tu
dansais très bien et que tu dansais
aussi je me le roc noir
alors je lui de chanter le taux voté
voir mon lit
dorothée avec toi je veux danser
dorothée avec toi tu te sens du fou les
et on va bien rigoler
il a longtemps vécu
quand venait le temps
m
la bouche de beaucoup plus calme
maintenant monsieur bien une petite
berceuse
on va je dois la panthère tu veux la
panthère c'est la première rose mais on
est tombé dans un encrier alors la
petite berceuse ça fait ça
dès lors sur ton oreiller je viendrai
s'éveiller d'or d'or
dorothée dans la nuit de l'été les
oiseaux chantent du rêve rêve de voter
au dessin animé aux histoires
et très fort m dos
laissez-moi parmi nous
dans tes yeux aux ouvriers là
une
but
je crois qu'à moi même
amélie
mouallem
on est tranquille dans les cantons où on
est bien la reine on peut discuter
horrible tacle